I was going to break up with Ariana
regardless but you didn't Mr Boss run
instead I mean Raquel became like really
good friends I don't give a
no it's not yes it is you know
everything
Ariana Maddox unleashing on X Tom
Sandoval in the just released trailer
for Vanderpump Rules season 10 finale I
am my own person and I have very strong
opinions of my own the new clip
showcasing the explosive aftermath of
Ariana learning about Sandoval's affair
with Raquel Levis which ended their
nine-year relationship it turned out so
horribly wrong yeah that's our first
glimpse of Sandoval and Raquel cozying
up after the big reveal though the signs
were there all along with scene shot
last summer now appearing to hold a
secret you get a lot of
the trailer also features the group's
reaction to scandival and no one's happy
I was going to break up with Ariana
regardless but you didn't after bus run
instead you think this is the first time
he's been creeping around it was one
other time come on how long have you
known Tom told me this a month ago are
you inside of all an item now Raquel no
it's always been about a group of people
that are so inextricably entwined and
love each other but also so volatile
volatile's a word Lisa is used to
describe Kristen Dodie before too
Lisa no yep I'm saying it I don't care
I'm over it
Sandoval's ex makes her highly
anticipated return in the finale too
you ready
you don't deserve any of this we're
still a couple weeks away from seeing it
all go down that episode won't air until
May 17th and then comes the reunion and
more than likely season 11. well
machinations and Dynamics it was like
you threw it all up in the air and
you've got to see where it lands right
now it's the myth I don't know if we can
sort it out I know
yeah but hey I have hope Lisa Vanderpump
and Ariana stepped out for the White
House correspondence dinner just days
before Bravo dropped that trailer and
Lisa had some things to say about
scandival the magic of this
official eyes and their feelings is what
keeps people engaged and there's a lot
of people that have tried to mimic us
and try to create shows but without the
authenticity a real friendship that's
why it hurts that's why people bled by
Ariana because they were invested in
real relationships and that's what
life's about
as for Ariana she shared what she's
learned about herself while living
through it all that I can do anything
handle anything
but I'm gonna leave it at that I regret
ever loving you
foreign